Clocking in at two hours and thirty-five minutes,
The Last Jedi is easily the longest of the
Star Wars films.
But there were still a lot of important scenes
that ended up on the cutting room floor, with
director Rian Johnson promising 20 minutes
of deleted scenes when the Blu-ray comes out.
So what can fans expect?
Here's a spoiler-filled peek at the Last Jedi
scenes you didn't see.
Bromance
Early in The Last Jedi, fans got to see a
brief reunion between Poe Dameron and Finn
after the former stormtrooper woke up from
his medically induced coma.
Originally, though, there was a longer sequence
where Poe brings Finn up to speed on what's
happened to the Resistance since he was injured.
Editor Bob Ducsay told Slash Film that fans
of the bromance will love it, saying,
"It's a really, really good character scene.
The only reason it's not in the movie is just
because of time.
I really love that scene."
Hey, flyboy
Before Vice Admiral Holdo proved herself by
heroically sacrificing her life to save the
Rebellion, fans weren't quite sure what to
think of her thanks to her combative relationship
with Poe.
Originally, though, she was apparently much
worse, to the point where Johnson cut some
of their scenes together and had actress Laura
Dern re-record her dialogue in others to make
her less condescending.
Though, to be fair, Poe totally had it coming
after his terrible plan nearly doomed the
entire galaxy.
Love triangle
Whether you ship Finn and Rose, Finn and Poe,
or Finn and Rey, there's one deleted scene
of particular interest, where Rose and Finn
discuss Finn's feelings for Rey.
When Rose, who clearly has a thing for Finn,
suggests he's pining for Rey, he denies it
and says that he was "raised to fight," but
that he had never found anything worth fighting
for until Rey became his friend—emphasis
on friend.
Hmm!
Going undercover
Although Finn and Rose's storyline seems to
go on forever, it turns out originally it
was even longer, as a number of scenes in
their undercover mission aboard Snoke's Star
Destroyer ended up being cut.
Johnson told Collider,
"It's a full sequence of stuff with them sneaking
through this big office area of the Mega Destroyer
and then having to fake out these Stormtroopers."
And one of those Stormtroopers was apparently
played by Tom Hardy, who originally had a
speaking role that ended up on the cutting
room floor.
According to Slash Film, Hardy's stormtrooper
has an American "southern" accent, and apparently
is an acquaintance of Finn's from his First
Order days.
When they run into each other on an elevator,
Hardy's stormtrooper stares at Finn for several
seconds before blurting out, "I know who you
are….
FN-2187!
Damn boy, I never took you for officer material!"
Gunslinger Phasma
Is there any character in the new trilogy
that has been as underserved as poor Captain
Phasma?
She looks cool, but gets nothing to do - except
when she's being tossed in a dumpster or killed
off.
But in a deleted scene, Phasma actually got
to be awesome for once.
During Finn's mission aboard the Star Destroyer,
he tries to convince a squad of Stormtroopers
to quit the First Order and join him in the
rebellion by revealing it was Phasma who gave
him the codes to lower the shields to Starkiller
Base in The Force Awakens.
Before the stormtroopers can make up their
minds, though, Phasma shows up, whips out
her blaster, and mows down the entire unit
singlehandedly.
Luke's third lesson
If you were keeping count while watching The
Last Jedi, you might've noticed that Luke
never gave Rey his promised "third lesson"
during their Jedi training.
Johnson has promised fans that this "massive
sequence" will appear in the deleted scenes
when the Blu-ray drops in mid-2018.
So what happens in this sequence, which was
teased in the trailer with a brief shot of
Rey running across the beach?
Essentially, Luke fakes an attack on the island,
seemingly putting innocents in danger to illustrate
to Rey how outdated the Jedi's code of balance
is.
Rey is not happy about the deception, though,
probably because all this stuff about non-interference
sounds just a little… too familiar.
"I'm bound by the rules of the United Federation
of Planets, which order me not to interfere
with other worlds, other cultures.
If I were to tell them any of this, I'd violate
the Prime Directive."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!